[Musik]
etwas gedacht und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video ja heute ich hoffe
ich natürlich jetzt gut
das habe ich ja schon drei mal genau so
gesagt hey was geht ab jetzt willkommen
bei einem neuen video ja ich hoffe
natürlich geht es nicht gut ich bin auch
mal sehr gespannt wie es mir morgen ja
gut sind ja nur 24 stunden leute heute
vor einer woche kam ein erstes oder was
heißt mein erstes also zumindest mein
erstes 24 stunden video von der reihe
die jetzt jeden dienstag um 19 uhr kommt
wenn ihr euch das sich hinter die ohren
geschrieben hat macht das jetzt mal
schnell weil es gibt hier zahlt jeden
dienstag um 19 uhr ein neues 24 stunden
video von alex reid und heute wirklich
ein krasser part ich habe im internet
astronauten essen gefunden also mehr
wirklich viele von euch unter meine
videos kommentieren oder halt oder den
letzten part kommentiert alex wie
sieht's mit vielen zu einem schönen
astronauten ist ein aus oder dachte ich
so gut war solchen dass herr kriegen
aber man kann solche sachen wirklich im
internet bestellen im internet gibt es
ja heutzutage irgendwie fast alles und
ja ich habe zwei sachen gestellt zwei
pakete dieses paket ist echt schwer hier
sind getränke drin glaube ich also halt
so getränke die als
nahrungsergänzungsmittel gelten und halt
auch so ganze mahlzeiten ersetzen sollen
bin ich mal gespannt
und hier haben wir dann so
eingeschweißtes zeug drin so
eingeschweißte äpfel und so ich bin mal
also hatte ich weiß noch nicht was ich
von halten soll
aber gut wir packen das erst mal aus
obwohl eins muss ich euch direkt mal
zeigen das ganze hat mich glaube ich
insgesamt 60 euro gekostet wir haben
hier nämlich einmal drei liter von
astronauten der nahrung saturo
trinknahrung vanille und hier drin haben
wir dann fünfter park astronaut weltraum
nahrung frucht zum essen fünf parks
orten bündel bananen äpfel trauben
erdbeere 4 sicher eigentlich habe ich
auch noch so eiscreme bestellt die kommt
allerdings erst in einer woche oder so
habe ich gerade gesehen da ja das sollte
eigentlich reichen aber das paket das
liegt höchstens ich weiß nicht deswegen
vielleicht 150 gramm
und das hat 730 euro gekostet alles klar
also sagen wir fangen einfach noch den
getränken an
o-ton saturo completely gute also wenn
du unterwegs bist einfach so ein getränk
mit ist dann wie mittags ist wenn man es
gerade 13 uhr 21 das heißt das ganze
geht wieder bis morgen um 13 uhr 21 oder
halt wieder diese stumpfen drei
mahlzeiten vielleicht sagt dass ihr dem
einhalten von euch sogar was ob alle 23
euro für 8 grings ist okay ist natürlich
jetzt nicht wenig aber jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt leuchte aha ok astronauts hier
wirklich eigentlich fast nichts drinnen
also das ist so leicht wir haben hier 14
gramm pro packung was das denn
also das jetzt hier sich erdbeere red
eagles krebs was auch immer das ist
apfel und banane ja also das hier ist
mein essen für die nächsten 24 stunden
ob das reicht ich weiß ich wenn die
dinger rein ballern dann schon sonst
nicht weil du willst du denn hier mit
410 gramm bananen bahn ihr das sind
sogar 21 ja ich habe mich natürlich
vorher so ein bisschen im internet
schlau gemacht darüber und hat natürlich
auch so ausschau gehalten nach
mahlzeiten die vielleicht ein bisschen
deftiger sind nudeln irgendwie das ding
ist so was kannst du alles nicht
bestellen bei früher mussten die
astronauten wirklich kommt hier leben
die ganze zeit heutzutage ist das ein
bisschen anders da haben wohl die ganzen
raumstationen auch so köche die das
essen zubereiten dann dürfen sich die
astronauten aber das wünschen
und dann wird das da hoch geschickt und
dann gibt es auch manchmal dass anja aus
der dose oder so das ding ist nur das
essen da oben so stand das halt im
internet bin ich euch auch sehr gerne
mal kurz ein verändert seinen geschmack
wenn es da oben ist zumindest halt bei
menschen weil ich diese
geschmacksknospen die man ja auf der
zunge hat wohl in besonderer höhe
verändern stand da so ist wohl auch noch
nicht bewiesen aber gut
ja ich würde sagen wir fangen einfach
mal mit so einem ding kann ich bei aller
mir direkt mal zwei hier steht drauf hey
in protein 27 vitamine und mineralien
kein hunger für zwei bis drei stunden
frist noch wann
ja das ist gar nicht gut
ach du scheiße das schmeckt irgendwie
sehr nach aufgeweicht ein brötchen mit
so ein bisschen vanille drin und dieses
packung aromaten und auch dabei war das
wahrscheinlich schon ein bisschen länger
hier drin ist aber ich kann mir
vorstellen dass das wirklich gut sagt
ich deswegen haben wir das jetzt mal weg
[Musik]
war ganz entspannt also man merkt auf
jeden fall das ist direkt ein bisschen
sättigt ich weiß jetzt nicht ob ich
gleich wieder um gehabt gerade jetzt
nicht aber ich würde ganz gerne auch
schon mal dass hier das drin zumindest
einmal um euch zu zeigen wie das
aussieht weil das interessiert mich
raten wir fangen einfach mal mit den
bananen an junge was dass leute das sind
getrocknete bananenscheiben
[Musik]
wir sind eigentlich vorstellen wie eklig
dass gerade ist ich habe letzte woche 24
stunden gefängnis essen gemacht das war
purer luxus dagegen boris täglich wir
sehen uns die leute werden schon etwas
später ich muss jetzt noch ein kauft
wenn er nächstes video
falls ihr letztes video noch nicht
gesehen habe jüngst dem essen sex in
tv-spots also was macht man damit
essen halt möglichst schmackhaft
aussieht zeigt dass auf jeden fall ab
denn ich gehe jetzt noch einkaufen
zweiten partie übrigens den jungen und
den augen der nämlich jetzt noch mit man
werde ich wieder da bin mach ich mich
mal hier dran
also ich bin eigentlich so jemand der
mega viel ist aber nur diese wahl
allerdings keine ahnung aber das ist
wirklich scheiße ich habe überlegt
morgenfrühe mache ich mal so ein müsli
dann nehme ich das als milch und tun
diese ganzen sachen da rein leute ganz
kurze und sehr wichtig weil wir schon
mal dabei sind trägt auf jeden fall
meinen instagram ab denn da wäre ich
jetzt wieder aktiver da gibt es für die
nächsten 365 tage jeden tag ein foto
freut sich ja auch ganz einfach alex wie
also sollte ich mich finden ansonsten
auch in der beschreibung würde ich mich
sehr freuen wenn ihr dann voller last
jetzt geht es weiter
nein das ist ja ziemlich kalt draußen
ich habe diese packung jetzt einfach
gerade mal eine stunde und
herauszustellen dass man auch bei einem
kollegen von mir
und die ist jetzt schon relativ kalt
eben was ja warm mal gucken ob es jetzt
besser schmeckt ich habe davon einfach
schon gleich einen liter drin nach kasse
sogar made in germany hab ich eben gar
nicht gesagt was da genau drin ist kann
ich aber irgendwie nicht ermitteln ja
schon besser kalt eins ist ganz klar da
fehlt auf jeden fall der zucker wenn ihr
zucker drin wer wird das glaube ich echt
geil ich melde mich geht es erst mal
einkaufen ich hoffe ich finde alle
sachen die haben möchte weil das nächste
video wird wirklichkeit also da könnt
ihr euch werkstoff freuen kommt am
donnerstag oder freitag
ja das ist gleich so leute das hier sind
jetzt einige der sache nicht dafür
braucht werden glücklicherweise noch
einen burger gefunden
scheißegal ich will nicht zu viel
verraten alles gut hälfte habe ich noch
man kommt irgendwie so langsam auf den
geschmack jetzt habe ich schon ein
italia
so leute wieder zurück wollte ich jetzt
zumindest noch mal heute hier diese
ganzen snacks ausprobieren ich meine
diese bananen länger ich habe eben noch
mal probiert die sind so eklig alter das
könnt ihr nicht vorstellen
ganze acht das ist sogar alles made in
usa seit 1974 das jetzt glauben soll
weiß ich aber machen wir also hier
wusste ich jetzt sagen haben wir erdbeer
stücke die riechen wirklich gut sind
halt auch getrocknet sind finde ich
jetzt eigentlich ganz lecker aus ich
probiere mal 1 ich weiß nicht also ich
muss wirklich sagen diese drinks hier
finde ich eigentlich am besten die gibt
es übrigens auch noch von schokolade und
erdbeer dieses ganze getrocknet zeug
schmeckt irgendwie nicht gut
ich will gar nicht gut ich bin mal
gespannt wie dann morgen für meinen
müsli schmecken wir aber ich auch etwas
interessantes zu gelesenen alle
mahlzeiten müssen ja irgendwie so eine
bestimmte big flüssigkeit haben damit
die sicherheit nicht in der
schwerelosigkeit praktisch auflösen und
dann die motoren zum beispiel
beschädigen entwickeln das heute noch
ist kein plan jetzt hier aber die halter
ok comdirect man hier so ein großer mann
braucht er die vitamine das wieder durch
also diese drinks habe ich mich
eigentlich schon gewöhnt das hier ist
grausam
ich habe auch schon gar keinen hunger
mehr wert ist so eklig ist ich hab
natürlich wasser getrunken so ganz klar
aber ich habe dort mit drei packungen
von diesem jahr gegessen und ein paar
bananen stücke diese erdbeere sieht
wirklich aus wie eine erdbeere ich jetzt
auf jeden fall penan ich leg waren alles
auf das mich hier
und ja vielleicht kann das was heute
guten morgen ich muss das leider ein
bisschen verschieben weil ich sonst
seitdem ich schaffe ich habe jetzt
nämlich einen wichtigen termin
privat kann man so sagen und ich muss
jetzt dringend los also das tut mir leid
aber das machen wir noch heute abend
dann ist dann jetzt leider so kann ich
nichts machen ich will das nicht
schaffen das spiel sollte was geht
herzlich willkommen zurück
ja tut mir wirklich leid eigentlich
wollte ich das ganze heute morgen schon
fertig gestellt haben
aber ich bin ehrlich
ich habe ich nicht geschafft ihr kennt
ja vielleicht sehen wir manchmal ist man
von dem stress zuvor so veranstaltungen
und morgen so weiß ich habe heute das
jetzt ganz normal gegessen
jetzt wollte ich aber auf jeden fall
noch das müsli probieren guck mal da
sieht man schon wie dickflüssig halt
dieses vanille zeug ist natürlich jetzt
früchte rein
die habe ich noch gar nicht gezeigt weiß
doch gar nicht was das ist
und hier habe ich noch ganz ausgemacht
die balladen sind übrigens schon leer
also ich muss sagen so eklig sieht das
gar nicht aus wenn ich mal gespannt ob
das auch oder ob man das besser essen
kann als die sachen einzel kann ja sein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
als j vielfältiger vorgestellt die
früchte schmecken gar nicht mehr so
schlecht
sobald der halt was da drin ist wir sind
ne ganz gut
es ist kein echtes sein dass ich das
falsch gemacht habe dass ich hier
einfach wasser zu geben hätte müssen wo
wir noch kurz die erdbeere hier also
darf ich sagen das überrascht mich
gerade weil das geht auf jeden fall
recht klar
ich habe mir gedacht auftakt das war
früher noch kinder weil da vermischungen
daraus wird also für den heutigen part
muss sagen ich habe es eigentlich ganz
durchgezogen wir nächste woche aber wir
haben schreibt mir auf jeden fall ideen
kommentare die ich umsetzen kann und
aber manchmal gespannt welche challandes
nächste woche ansteht vielleicht
interessant auch mal wieder das mal zu
sehen war dass wir auch teuer aber gute
leute das war's mir wieder haut rein
check auf jeden fall mein instagram ab
da gibt es jetzt jeden tag ein foto für
die nächsten 365 tage die 365 tage
challenge als ich alex w und ja das was
von mir haut rein